[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo on va refaire
l'actualité politique parlementaire bien
évidemment aux 30 minutes mojo katia
bonjour michael et nous accueillons
cette semaine christian jacob
bonjour bonjour président du groupe
l'est républicain à l'assemblée
nationale et député de la 4e
circonscription de seine-et-marne
on va revenir avec vous sur le discours
d' emmanuel macron devant les maires de
france réuni à paris le président de la
république a annoncé une refonte en
profondeur de la fiscalité locale
accueillie par quelques sifflets le
budget 2010 8 le premier de la
législature a été voté en première
lecture à l'assemblée 356 voix pour 175
contre c'est au tour des sénateurs
d'examiner puis et députés ont achevé
l'examen des cinq ordonnances pour
réformer le code du travail vote
solennel prévu mardi prochain
et puis christian jacob on parlera aussi
de cette proposition de loi qui vise à
instaurer un principe de galles
d'alterner pour les enfants sujets de
société sensibles
vous l'avez dit tiens on commence
évidemment par les maires de france et
le président de la république et s'est
présenté de preuves
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'était un discours fleuve et le
président a tenté de cajoler les maires
et dans le même temps il est resté ferme
quand même sur ses positions le résumé
et les réactions avec quentin calme est
arrivée au congrès des maires sous
quelques huées emmanuel macron était
très attendue par les maires et en
particulier sur un sujet la taxe
d'habitation
ça fait plus de 40 ans dans notre pays
on dit cet impôt est injuste il faut en
revoir les bases la grammaire
l'architecturé et à chaque fois on
renonce et qui est la victime de cette
affaire
je vais vous le dire les territoires les
plus modestes et les classes moyennes
sujet après sujet emmanuel macron
rassure au point de convaincre des élus
souvent hostile sur le sujet des
finances locales également un petit peu
retourné les maires qui était vraiment
là nos positions violentes la
suppression partielle de la taxe
habitation
nous n'avions pas certains éléments qui
nous souhaitons est clairement
aujourd'hui je pense qu'effectivement
les discours étaient bons
mais bon sang de bonsoir qu'on m'a dit
le coma ni le président on se mettra
autour d'une table avec beaucoup de
rayons beaucoup de concertation il faut
que ça soit suivi d'effets de leur côté
les maires des grandes villes présent à
paris retienne les autres ambitions du
chef de l'état l'annnonce de la grande
réforme de fiscalité locale ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on attend depuis très
très longtemps
l'annoncé d'une grande conférence du
logement pour discuter de tous les
sujets et non pas prendre les choses par
le petit bout qui fâche le plus comme ça
a été le cas jusqu'ici
l'annnonce du rapprochement entre
métropoles les plus importantes et
département donc ça ce sont des des
sujets importants
je dirais que sur 80 % de ce que le
président a apporté comme réponse à des
questions précises sur l'autonomie
fiscale sur l'autonomie des territoires
sur des engagements sur la durée ces
propos ont été à mon sens extrêmement
rassurant prochaine étape de cet échange
entre les maires et le président de la
république le 14 décembre pour la
prochaine rencontre de la conférence des
territoires christian jacob je vais vous
dire satisfaits rassurés heureux côté on
assiste est d'abord un discours sur la
forme le long et ennuyeux quand même
cela qui qui qui est ressorti les
d'ailleurs beaucoup de maires ont quitté
l'ont quitté la salle parce que ça ça
n'en finissait plus est
et après ce cas rien pour eux qu'est ce
qui change
qu'est ce qu'il y a 2 de concret
d'habitation éventuellement 2020
l'horizon supprimé pour cent pour cent
c'est ce que vous réclamiez aussi non la
taxe d'habitation oui mais quand on le
président de la république et explique
qui va qui est pénalisé qui va être
pénalisé siddiqui qui va être pénalisé
on le sait ces contribuables puisque on
remplace cet impôt par de la dette et de
l'impôt national ce qui était payée par
l'impôt l'eau le contribuable local
c'est le contribuable national qui va le
payer puisque si effectivement il tient
parole sur la compensation c'est soit de
l'année près à l'euro près la baisse de
la taxe d'état vin payant c'est un
dégrèvement
eh bien oui quel état va payer donc
c'est le contribuable est assez vous
l'état c'est moi
l'état c'est le contribuable c'est pas
monsieur mâcon qui sort sa d'une poche
dire la facture ça va la dette le
déficit et avec un impôt qui sera plus
beaucoup plus éloigné du citoyen et donc
on voit bien à chaque fois qu'on est
éloigné de nos décisions s'éloigne de
nos concitoyens et bien on a toutes
sortes de dérapages ya plus ce contrôle
direct qu'il pouvait y avoir localement
ce que dira on le supprime c'est se
moquer du monde
la réalité c'est que s'ils suppriment et
qu il le compense faut qu'on m'explique
ce que l'on va gagner à supprimer un
impôt local pour le remplacer par un
impôt national et alourdir la dette de
l'état qu'est ce que vous avez entendu
comme discours dont qui est long et
ennuyeux je veux dire c'est pas dire que
quand les maires de france attendent le
président de la république et qui
quittent les uns après les autres la
salle parce que c'est en finit plus il
arrive avec du retard mais ça c'est à
chaque fois et ensuite un discours qui
n'en finit pas quand je vous entends
depuis tout à l'heure vous dites donc
les questions de l'impôt et des classes
moyennes quelque part qui vont peut-être
subir les conséquences
alors que le président hier a expliqué
que c'était justement fait pour les
classes moyennes et vous obtenez mais
tombait attendez on va arrêter deux
secondes qui paient l'impôt sur le
revenu en france c'est paris classé sur
deux après on sait bien les classes
moyennes c'est eux qui payent l'impôt
sur le revenu et quand le président de
la république dit aux communes mais
rassurez vous on va compenser mais qui
va le payer attendait faut réfléchir
deux secondes deux secondes à cela moi
je préfère un impôt qui soient
collectées au plus proche possible du
terrain utilisé qu'ils soient dynamiques
au sikkim est en responsabilité les
équipes municipales j'étais 15 en mer on
n'est jugé là dessus sur la manière dont
on utilise la peau là on dira écoutez
c'est l'état donc mettre à plat la
fiscalité notamment la fiscalité
communale comme ça a été promis pour
vous ça n'a pas de sens sans ben ça
c'est autre chose mais mais là on est
dans le discours on est dans le verbe à
savoir que du verbe
oui voilà ce qu'on nous explique
2020-2022 bon bah oui c'est sûr qu'il
peut parler pour dans deux quinquennats
on verra ce qui se passera après mais
concrètement aujourd'hui là dessus c'est
du verbe
en revanche la taxe d'habitation
effectivement on la transfère sur le
contribuable
on a beaucoup entendu parler
à droite du président des métropoles les
critiques vis-à-vis de manuel macro
après ce que vous avez entendu hier soir
vous confirmer tout cela oui bah il y a
un problème relationnel
enfin relationnel et je pense de mes
connaissances parce que selon son
parcours qui est très respectable
d'inspecteur des finances de hauts
fonctionnaires donc c'est que vous
prétendez métro oui il a une approche
quand même beaucoup plus urbaines que
rurales c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
et toute cette france des des
territoires sur lesquels d'ailleurs nous
nous travaillons beaucoup à ces maires
ruraux ne se retrouvent pas danser dans
ses grands discours
parce que les maires ruraux it sont ils
sont confrontés au concret qui était la
baisse des dotations avec le
gouvernement hollande est aujourd'hui on
continue comme ça sans nous ou nos
caisses
c'était logique est différente
le gel cette continuité françois
hollande c'est la continuité parce que
quand ils nous expliquent mais la
regarder j'arrête de baisser les
dotations soit mais quand on supprime
les emplois aidés à la revient bien ou
même pour les collectivités parce que la
collectivité
elle a besoin les emplois aidés c'est
quoi on les retrouve où on les retrouve
dans les centres aérés
on les retrouve dans les écoles et donc
il faut bien les compenser et si on
baisse les ans on va parler du budget
christian jacob qui a été votée cette
semaine le projet de loi de finances
pour 2018
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est un vote en première lecture ce
budget entérine la transformation de l'
isf la disparition progressive de la
taxe d'habitation il vise aussi à
respecter les limites de déficit public
autorisée par bruxelles
le récapitulatif de marion châtelain
l'assemblée nationale a adopté le projet
de loi de finances pour 2018 avec 356
voix pour 175 voix contre et 27
abstentions
le premier budget du quinquennat macron
a été adopté sans surprise à une large
majorité les députés en marche et modem
ont unanimement voté en faveur de ce
projet de loi de finances pour amélie de
montchalin ce texte est une première
étape majeure du quinquennat et on à la
fois un budget qui est sincère amitié
qui le reflet de nos engagements
présidentiels et de nos campagnes
législatives et surtout un budget qui
cadrent toute action publique du
quinquennat pourtant ce budget n'a pas
rassemblé à droite de l'hémicycle
plus de la moitié des députés
constructif se sont abstenus principales
mesures mises en cause la hausse de la
csg ya des insuffisances voire des
fautes comme parlante celle de la csg il
aurait mieux valu mettre en place cette
fameuse tva compétitivité donc on a
essayé d'apporter une contribution on
essayer d'amender gouvernement il resté
sur ses positions
les députés les républicains ont tous
voté contre à une abstention près gilles
carez dénonce une majorité hégémonique
il n'y a pas eu de débat de fond pas un
seul amendement de l'opposition qu'elle
soit l'opposition de droite ou la
position de gauche n'a été adoptée par
un seul amendement moi c'est du jamais
vu
enfin aucune surprise à gauche les
députés communistes nouvelle gauche et
insoumis ont voté contre à l'unanimité
et pour eric coquerel
ce texte ne fait qu'accentuer les
inégalités c'est le plus inégal et
austère de la vème république
avec 9 milliards de cadeaux donnés aux
plus riches détenteurs de capitaux et la
note va être payée par tout le monde
voilà donc le medef veut sourire et les
français peuvent pleurer le projet de
loi de finances doit désormais être
examiné par le sénat
son adoption définitive se fera au plus
tard le 22 décembre prochain
vous avez voté contre christian jacob
oui et alors on entendu gilles carez
notre collègue qui dit pas un seul
amendement de l'opposition accepté que
ce soit de la gauche ou de la droite et
c'est le cas est ce que les droits de
nos positions sont bafoués à ce point il
ya une vraie hégémonie comme on l'a
jamais connue dans ça commençait
d'ailleurs moins que sous le quinquennat
de hollande avec l'interdiction de cumul
des mandats mais confirmé d'ailleurs
uniquement pour les députés mais j'ai
découvert comme moi que ça ne concernait
pas les ministres qui est un vrai semble
hélas sur le budget vous êtes si sûr à
bains sur le sur le budget l'opposition
alors que notamment précédent
gouvernement elles sont sachant que
c'était pas c'était pas nous non plus
très très facile mais on arrivait dans
le débat budgétaire parfois à faire
bouger des choses absolument rien là on
a une équipe c'est pas moi qui ai qu'il
l'ait dit mais la phrase est repris par
tous maintenant une équipe de playmobil
voilà qui les députés de la majorité
quoi qu'il se passe quoi qu'il dise vote
sans réfléchir à rien sans débat
d'ailleurs en interne pour eux c'est
d'ailleurs très frustrant parce qu'on
voit bien qu'il ya pas non plus de
débats à l'intérieur du groupe droits de
la vie sont bafoués les droits de
l'opposition sont absolument bafouée ne
sont pas reconnus c'était la manoeuvre
souvenez vous qu on a pu corriger ce qui
s'est passé avec avec les questeurs les
questeurs le budget de l'assemblée
nationale c'est pas rien c'est 500
millions de 500 millions d'euros mis
uniquement entre les mains monsieur des
amis de monsieur macron pour la première
fois depuis 74
il n'y avait pas de représentants de
l'opposition dans le collège des
questeurs c'est là la même chose là avec
monsieur castaner qu'on va maintenir
comme mini chargé des relations avec le
avec le parlement soit question de
budget le sénat va se pencher aussi
maintenant il va récupérer le budget
dans ils sont en train de l'examiner
vous seriez d'accord vous par exemple
sur une question très précise qui est
l'un concerne qui concerne le logement
on propose par exemple de monter deux à
10%
c'est un sénateur de droite qui le
proposent de 10% sur la tva sur la
rénovation notamment des travaux de
rénovation dans les appartements vous
êtes d'accord pour soutenir je suis moi
j'étais favorable à l'idée de la tva
qu'on avait appelé la tva compétitive
c'est à dire ceux nicolas sarkzoy là
cette augmentation de tva qui nous
permettait de financer une partie de la
protection sociale c'est à dire qu'on
affectés à la protection sociale
donc ça représentait un double avantage
c'est à dire qu'on n'augmente pas le
coût du travail avec des cotisations
supplémentaires pour boucler le budget
de la sécu et ça nous permettait aussi
de faire financer la protection sociale
par une partie des importations vous
êtes quand une entreprise se délocalise
vous avez moins d'activité en france
donc moins de cotisations qui rentre et
ses produits qui sont fabriqués à
l'extérieur et bien lorsqu'ils
reviennent sur le sol français il paie
de la tva est donc là on pouvait
effectivement baissé enfin contribuer à
financer la notre système de protection
sociale donc dans ce cadre là moi je
suis favorable à ce qu'on touche à la
tva mais pour baisser le coût des chefs
pour faire recette fiscale faut arrêter
pour faire des réformes de structure
aucune réforme de structure ont fait ce
qu'ils veulent et d'enseignement la
réforme de structure notamment salue les
ordonnancements en parler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est peut-être pas à vos yeux une
réforme de structure mais c'était une
promesse de campagne du candidat
emmanuel macron maintenant devenu
président il a semblé à terminer
d'examiner donc les cinq ordonnances qui
vont réformer le code du travail en
profondeur vote solennel aura lieu mardi
prochain on a beaucoup beaucoup entendu
la gauche sur les bancs de l'assemblée
nationale par contre à droite a beaucoup
pourquoi mais parce qu on a toujours à
jouer très clairement qu'on était
favorable c'est assez order c'est ce
texte cela nous l'avons déposé avec mon
collègue gérard cherpion jeu les déposer
en tant que président de groupe sur un
certain nombre de mesures qui vont dans
le même sens sous le quinquennat de
hollande il n'avait pas été retenu
donc on a toujours dit très clairement
que si le gouvernement reprenait nos
propositions on n'allait pas voter
contre tout simplement je sais que ces
propositions
donc il ya aucun problème et donc il
n'est pas de sujets là dessus quand on
est favorable on le vote mais on va pas
expliquer que c'est ça la grande réforme
de sol dur quand belge avec cette
réforme y rit il fait bouger la france
c'est quelque chose oui ça se traduit
comment enfin quelques places et yahia
l'intention est là ça fait des années
que les voiliers de oui sauf que les
réformes et de l'attrait d'un cul non
c'est très fort il est nécessaire encore
une fois on avait fait des propositions
mais qu'on nous explique pas qu'en
modifiant trois articles dans le code du
travail à va relancer l'emploi
suffisamment la réforme de structure
c'est de baisser la dépense publique
qu'est ce qui est fait par exemple sur
les les fonctionnaires je m'amusais hier
j'entendais le président de la
république nous faire ses grandes
déclarations
quand je promets quelque chose je tiens
mes promesses
oui enfin on attend la démonstration il
avait il ne tient pas ses promesses à
bâillonnement voulons clairement quand
il a annoncé qu'il allait baisser de
120000 les emplois publics
ça faisait très concrètement 24 mille
emplois publics de moins dans le dans le
budget ce qui n'est pas énorme mais
enfin c'était ça en moins la réalité ces
trois centres pour vous cette invention
c320 quand le président de la république
annonce qu'il fait vingt-quatre mille
par an et qu'il en fait 300 ha on peut
expliquer que c'est une vérité en face
et quand même une vérité bien détournée
quand il annonce très clairement dans le
son programme également qui va remettre
en place la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires manche partout c'est ce
que vous menez j'ai nommé jeudi pas
partout le procès deux points est ce que
oui ou non il a remis en place la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
la réponse est non est ce que oui ou non
ils annoncé dans son programme la
réponse est oui
donc à partir du mans il ne fait pas il
a menti enfin on peut m'expliquer les
choses comme on veut est ce que oui ou
non il a annoncé qu'il fallait faire et
qu'ils allaient baisser de 120 mille
emplois publics
la réponse est oui est ce qu'il le fait
la réponse est non voilà c'est tout
c'est l'effet question à les discours
c'est pas du blabla d'une heure c et 10
c c'est la réalité des faits question à
présent la garde alternée des enfants
doit elle devenir la règle
et bien ce sujet de société sans s'il
était examinée à l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une proposition de loi venue des
députés du modem qui institue la garde
alternée comme principe en cas de
séparation des parents
un sujet sensible qui a provoqué de vifs
débats explications de maïté frémont
c'était un accouchement difficile pour
le premier texte du modem la proposition
de loi sur la garde alternée a été
adopté mais au prix d'un travail complet
de réécriture de l'article de la part du
rapporteur modem et de la porte parole
du groupe la république en marche la
proposition elle est peut-être mal
rédigé donc nous ne l'avons pas
dénaturer nous avons tâché puisque c'est
notre métier dégustateurs métier notre
travail de législateur de faire en sorte
d'améliorer les textes une réponse à
l'accusation des députés les
républicains les deux groupes de la
majorité sont accusés de s'être arrangé
pour rectifier le tir à la va vite un
texte est proposée par modem qui
maintenant de la tête voter pour la
majorité par groupes en marché donc il
ya effectivement des arrangements qui
ont été faits pour pouvoir avoir un
texte qui soit réduit effectivement
parfois ses intentions initiales mais
qui ne correspond plus du tout
effectivement ou titre de dépens image
d'unité des deux groupes alliés a
toutefois été écornée par un amendement
le caractère provisoire ou non de la
décision du juge
je pense qu'on pourrait retravailler ce
point là parce que moi je crois que je
leur ai mis vraiment ailleurs je crains
que le délai provisoire aussi long soit
ils provoquent des tensions entre les
parts de cette période de décision
provisoire soit période d'observation en
fin de période probatoire
elle sera qui permet au juge d'avoir
tous les éléments ensuite pour prendre
une décision définitive
la droite les communistes la france en
soumises ont voté contre la proposition
laurence vichnievsky pourtant élu modem
s'est abstenu jugeant le contenu de
cette loi cosmétiques le texte
rebaptisée loi relative à la résidence
de l'enfant en cas de séparation des
parents sera examiné dans l'hémicycle à
partir du 30 novembre
christian jacob vous avez été ministre
la famille entre 2002 2004 intéressant
d'avoir votre position sur ce sujet est
ce que c'est le principe même de la
garde alternée qui vous pose problème ou
ce parce qu'on touche à la famille
quelle est votre position
moi je j'ai toujours été défavorable à
la généralisation et au fait d'imposer
la garde alternée
je pense que c'est un outil qui à la
disposition du du juge et il faut à
chaque fois avoir un soucis lorsqu'il y
as séparation des parents quel souci de
l'enfant et de voir ce qui est le mieux
adapté et donc déclarer que c'est
obligatoirement la garde alternée je
pense que c'est une erreur parce que
toutes les familles ne sont pas en
situation de le faire ça veut dire qu'il
faut avoir les caps des revenus des
capacités de logement d'hébergement des
enfants x de toutes les familles ne sont
pas c'est au moment du divorce il ya
beaucoup de drames et parfois aussi sur
le plan financier on n'a pas la capacité
chacun des deux parents n'a pas la
capacité donc ça peut pas devenir la
règle
ensuite lorsque les enfants sont très
jeunes ans je sais que c'est un sujet
qui fait souvent polémiques
moi je pense qu'il y a un lien très
particulier avec la mer 6 ans voilà
comme le 6 ans ou 3 c'est encore plus
vrai en dessous de 3 ans
mais mais ça l'est aussi un peu plus
tard mais est l'autre point c'est que
c'est aussi adapté donc un milieu csp +
plus urbain mais dès que vous êtes aussi
dans le dans le milieu rural ont fait
beaucoup de kilomètres pour aller
travailler ou parfois il ya des
obligations de déménagement il ya des
médiations que je pense qu'il faut être
prudent et penser à l'intérêt de
l'enfant et l'intérêt de l'enfant c'est
pas des règles systématique laissons le
juge apprécié que j'ai comme d'une jarre
à 7 avec notre partenaire du figaro
s'est tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour jean bonjour mickaël nogent
katia christian jacob
bonjour vous avez été l'un des plus
critiques cette semaine sur l'éventuelle
cumul de christophe castaner entre ses
fonctions de chef de parti et deux mini
vous avez d'ailleurs interpellé le
premier ministre edouard philippe sur le
sujet on vous écoute
cette décision si elle était confirmée
monsieur le premier ministre serait un
conflit d'intérêts caractériser ce
serait une caporalisation des députés ce
serait une mise en coupe réglée de
l'assemblée nationale avec en réalité un
seul objectif affaiblir le parlement
vous étiez monsieur le président jacob
membre d'un gouvernement qui comptait
dans ses rangs le président d'une
formation politique au poste au poste au
poste monsieur jacob de ministre de
l'intérieur
jim sa demande donc petite analyse tout
cela oui parce que donc vous étiez à
l'époque mise la fonction publique en
2005 et nicolas sarkozy en effet été
chef de parti et ministre
il a trouvé la parade edouard philippe
pour contrecarrer vos arguments non moi
l'argumentaire que j'ai toujours
développé les suivants et de dire le
ministre en charge des relations avec le
parlement c'est un rôle particulier ce
ministre s'est pas connu du grand public
mais est celui qui siège est le seul
membre du gouvernement qui siège à la
conférence des présidents ou sont réunis
l'ensemble des présidents de groupe à
l'assemblée et et où ils portent l'ordre
du jour l'ordre du jour de l'assemblée
est établie par le gouvernement et il y
à cette discussion avec les groupes donc
mettez vous à cette conférence ne
pouvait plus avoir confiance en
christophe castaner c'est à dire qu'on a
le président d'un parti et qui est là
d'ailleurs il ya un moment j'ai envie de
dire le premier qui devrait réagir c'est
françois de rugy
parce que mais il n'ya plus de près
autant que monsieur castaner président
de l'assemblée nationale président de la
conférence des présidents préside le
groupe parlementaire également en marche
quand qu'on aille au bout de ces temps
on a toujours veillé à on a toujours
tout les gouvernements ray le général
ont toujours veillé à mettre des
personnalités plutôt consensuel dans ce
poste parce que il ya effectivement un
équilibre à trouver
la cheffe de parti secret de
polichinelle que le ministre est rond
aussi en charge de soutenir un petit du
gouvernement donc comme le chef de parti
et doué vous savez on nous a expliqué et
monsieur edouard philippe
et pas le dernier à le faire que on
comprenait rien au monde qui avait
changé tout ça c'était le vieux monde
s'est terminée quelles références y
prendre nous explique des références on
remonte à jacques chirac il ya 30 ans en
cas qu'on nous a expliqué mais regardez
chirac en 86 comme ce qu'il faisait a
expliqué regarder nicolas sarkozy il ya
12 ou 15 ans comment il faisait et je
croyais qu'on était dans le nouveau
monde c'est comme sur le cumul des
mandats c'est quand même assez
hallucinant je vous dis un mot quand
même sur le cumul des mandats
ce qu'on veut on sort du congrès des
maires vous savez que vous ne pouvez
plus être député maire d'une commune de
300 habitants où même ou même adjoint
en revanche le ministre du budget et des
comptes publics alors lui
il peut être premier adjoint de
tourcoing ça ne pose aucun problème
c'est faites ce que je dis et faites pas
ce que je fais ça vous savez vous avez
un mélange lac est assez hallucinant
mais l'or à la fois il ya un côté la
fois des nouveaux convertis et
l'arrogance des nouveaux riches
alors on va parler dans le sujet qui est
l'élection à la présidence des
républicains on a appris cette semaine
qu'il n'y aura pas de débat puisque a
pas eu d'accord entre laurent wauquiez
vous que vous soutenez et les deux
autres candidats est ce que vous
regrettez cette absence de débat non non
parce que je pense que ça on a vu en
marche qui organisait un débat 270
téléspectateurs donc ça permet quand
même de relativiser
l'intérêt oui laurent wauquiez était à
provins et hier il y avait 400 personnes
dans la salle
bon je craignais pas une faible
mobilisation sur cette élection et du
cou par conséquent une faible légitimité
de laurent wauquiez à la tête du parti
non mais mais mais je note tout ce qui
est fait à la fois pour caricaturer
brocardé laurent wauquiez c'est à dire
que c'est pas tout non non non non mais
je veux dire tout et tout est beau il
est douteux
trente mille militants on sera fixé pour
la mi temps mais tout est fait pour le
déstabiliser
c'est maintenant comme on se dit bon
sans doute qui va être élu donc pour
expliquer que son élection ne serait pas
légitime
il faut arrêter non les militants votent
les militants qui souhaitent voter on
souhaite qu'ils soient plus nombreux
possible mais on est au lendemain d'une
défaite électorale et donc effectivement
il y aura sans doute moins de
participation que quand on est dans une
phase ascendante comme l'étaient les
dernières questions très rapidement on a
appris cette semaine la constitution du
parti agir en sera le futur parti dé
constructif
vous leur dites
adieu bonne chance et au revoir c'est
terminé aucune espèce d'importance
bon on a neuf députés qui ont décidé il
ya 100 députés au groupe l'est
républicain
neuf ont décidé de travailler en quelque
sorte leurs électeurs c'est quand même
ça la réalité ils sont partis ou
j'aurais trouvé plus logique qu'ils
aillent carrément en marche bon ils sont
un peu mal à l'aise là dessus donc léger
seulement tous à aucune espèce
d'importance
merci beaucoup christian jacob d'avoir
été l'invité de pareloup ainsi jim bonne
semaine à tous la semaine prochaine
[Musique]